[Music]  i want him to answer for what he has  done  for me  every scene has to have a stake  large or small  you have disgraced me come down  you knew what would happen to me should  you lose this duel  the message is simple what do i want the  audience to walk away  knowing  debating eugene they want us to leave  the bridge for the king  dynamic is a good word  dynamic can either be a moving car  something falling  a change of pace i need to get in at  that hatred that moment of hatred  confess  or just something we didn't expect  what we're doing here  is a good dynamic which is silence  i am telling the truth  we will proceed with the jewels  silas is a dynamic  [Music]  you